Thüringens Ministerpräsident Bodo ramelo
ist Mitunterzeichner der Initiative und
uns jetzt aus AF zugeschaltet guten
Morgen Herr Ministerpräsident guten
Morgen warum glauben sie könnte dieses
Bündnis den Ausschlag geben Menschen die
aus Protest AFD wählen wollen
umzustimmen erstmal ist es so dass sich
jetzt sehr sehr viele Menschen zu Wort
melden sehr viele Institutionen dabei
sind wir haben beides wir haben auf
einmal eine Bewegung auf den Straßen die
ich vor Monat noch nicht mal für möglich
gehalten hätte und das neue hinter
dieser Bewegung stehen nicht Parteien
oder Organisationen sondern auf einmal
wie in Weimar junge Studierende auf die
ich unglaublich stolz bin wenn ich sehe
dass 18 19 20-Jährige auf einmal
Demonstrationen anmelden und
organisieren die in ihrem Leben noch nie
politisch in irgendeiner Form aktiv
waren das ist etwas wirklich Neues und
parallel dazu hat sich dieses Bündnis
aufgebaut an dem ich
mit unterzeich reichner bin aber es ist
im Wesentlichen auch geprägt von jenen
Optik und Unternehmen die einfach sagen
wir haben 92 Weltmarktführer das heißt
wir wollen auf die Weltmärkte mit
Thüringer Produkten und wir sind es leid
dass auf der Welt über Thüringen seltsam
geredet wird als wenn die faschistische
Gefahr schon an der Tür steht und
anklopft und der Machtanspruch den er
höcke formuliert hat ist ja sehr
deutlich und was er will hat er in
seinem Buch sehr deutlich beschrieben
nämlich die Remi Migration als
alltagsthema auf die Tagesordnung zu
setzen und davor haben viele Menschen
Angst die als
migrationsbetroffene bei uns leben bei
uns arbeiten bei uns studieren allein an
der bauhausuniversität sind 105 Nationen
als Studierende und als Lehrende und die
haben in Weimar Angst dass sich das
wiederholt was wir schon mal erlebt
haben als die BA als das Bauhaus in
Weimar vertrieben wurde habe ich
verstanden Herr ramelo nun ist ihr Bild
das sie gerade aufgemacht haben mit dem
anklopfen gar nicht so fern weil in
Umfragen liegt die AFD bei über 30% in
ihrem Bundesland sie sind
Ministerpräsident wo liegen ihre
Versäumnisse verzeihen Sie wenn Sie
darauf rekorrieren dass es die Schuld
des Ministerpräsidenten ist dass der
Frust der Bevölkerung sich festmacht wir
haben die bauernproteste wir erleben
gerade eine Welle von Unverständnis
gegenüber Politik da bin ich ein
teilvertreter dieser Politik gegen die
hier tatsächlich das tägliche bching
organisiert wird das geht aber auch
gegen Journalisten das geht auch gegen
die Institutionen das geht gegen
gebührenfanzierten öffentlichrechtlichen
Rundfunk alle zusammen sind wir
diejenigen die als Gegner gekennzeichnet
werden auf den Kundgebungen in Gerra hat
man z.B einen Journalisten als Feind
gebrandmarkt in einer schuldig Kleidung
in der sonst ich immer nur abgebildet
würde also entschuldigen Sie bitte dass
es mir zu einfach ist wenn aus ihrer
Perspektive der Minister Präsident die
Verantwortung dafür hat dass wir eine
faschistische Partei in Deutschland
haben die überall sich aufgemacht hat
und den Hessen zweitstärkster geworden
ist in Bayern zweitstärkster geworden
ist das dann immer wieder auf
Ostdeutschland zu reduzieren halte ich
genauso für unangemessen ich habe nur
gefragt wo liegen ihre Versäumnisse ich
habe nicht gefragt dass ich habe nicht
gesagt dass sie Schuld haben ich würde
aber wenn es dazu kommt und viele
rechnen mit diesem Szenario dass die AFD
stark wird in Thüringen würden sie ein
Bündnis mit der CDU eingehen um einen
Ministerpräsidenten höcke zu verhindern
darf ich einfach darauf hinweisen dass
die Praxis die wir in Thüringen
praktizieren das dürfte ihn hinlänglich
bekannt sein seit di Jahren habe ich
keine Mehrheit in Deutschland hat noch
nie ein Ministerpräsident regiert der
keine eigene Mehrheit hat seit drei
Jahren haben wir jedes Jahr einen
Haushalt hinbekommen das heißt die
Demokraten im Thüringer Landtag haben es
geschafft seit dre Jahren immer wieder
zu guten Ergebnissen zu kommen dieses
Land ist nicht untergegangen dieses Land
ist nicht im Chaos versunken sondern
dieses Land hat in ungewöhnlichen
Situationen nach der kämerichwahl es
geschafft gemeinsam mit demokratischen
Mehrheiten im Parlament zu agieren das
alleine reicht aber nicht aus wir
brauchen ein gesellschaftliches Klima
dass das was in Italien zur Meloni
Regierung geführt hat was in Schweden zu
den Schwedendemokraten geführt hat in
den Niederlanden gerade dazu geführt hat
dass her Wilders die Wahl gewonnen hat
alles das passiert bei uns auch und
jetzt heißt es einfach darauf
hinzuschauen dass die überwiegend
Mehrheit nach wie vor demokratisch
gesindnt ist und nicht auf Herrn höcke
reinfallen möchte dann gibt es noch das
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht Herr
Ministerpräsident und dieses Bündnis
liegt den Umfragen vor ihrer Partei
aktuell und will mitregieren weren sie
ein möglicher
Bündnispartner schauen Sie Sarah
Wagenknecht wird in Thüringen gar nicht
kandidieren obwohl sie in Thüringen
geboren ist und deswegen sind die
Umfragen die sich immer wieder daran
festmachen würden sie Frau Wagenknecht
wählen etwas irreal weil Frau
Wagenknecht in Thüringen gar nicht auf
dem Wahlzettel stehen wird und wenn man
nach dem Bündnis jarer Wagenknecht fragt
muss man auch nach dem Bündnis von Frau
Dr Bergner ehemals FDP gemeinsam mit
Herrn Maßen bisher CDU die jetzt mit der
werteunion in Thüringen auch wiederum
eine neue Partei die als Schnittstelle
zur Volksfront von rechts beitragen
möchte diese Herausforderung werden wir
auch noch in den Umfragen bekommen
insoweit gehe ich jetzt erst in den
Wahlkampf und werde am 1 september um 18
Uhr
schauen wie viel für Demokratie sich
entschieden haben und ich hoffe dass die
CDU genauso dabei stark bleibt wie ich
auch hoffe dass meine Partei mit einem
guten Ergebnis ausgestattet in
Verhandlung eintreten kann sodass wir
wieder zu eigenen Mehrheiten in
Thüringen kommen werden sagt Thüringens
Ministerpräsident von der Linken Bodo
ramelo danke für das Gespräch heute
morgen gerne